- I am tripping right now I have told of
you'd lived through this they already
did your food yes a day reset when you
died right yeah I might be able to help
with that
I died eleven times I was stuck reliving
the same day over and over again into
someone wearing a baby mask ordered me
on the night of my birthday
turns out it was my roommate Laurie I
kicked her crazy ass out a window and
killed her which both to Luke but now
I'm living the better version of my life
[Applause]
okay yeah I folded your pants know how
to enter the loop but I'm back oh my god
everything's different this time it's
coming after all of us
if you don't reset the day and try again
they're dead for good aren't they so I'm
gonna have to die over and over again to
save all of you I mean I guess you could
just reset the day yourself genius idea
I don't stop the killing what people die
failure is not an option both this makes
my money on my mind got a middle of the
let's see what you got
Green crisis mode tree who's gonna
pledge Kappa now that we have a death
curse
[Applause]
you